and then so I go to this club and and
and I I'm on a list I don't know what
[__] list I'm on so I rock up to the
thing at 2: a.m. I'm like hey I'm on the
list they're like what list I'm like I
named some names the list I'm I named
some names they're like I need a table
number [__] table number I don't know
what that [__] is so I'm calling L
I'm like L can you can you what the [__]
am I on he's like I'll just come get you
so he comes out and gets me I go in and
I immediately like walk into this club
it's so loud obviously it's a club I
know it's loud but like the floor is so
sticky where it's like I'm walking like
this oh you're you're giv me somee
memories now I'm far too sober cuz I've
had like three beers where I need to be
like eight nine beers in for this
environment and L's living his best life
he's dancing he's having a great time
and I'm like to so I can't do it and
it's 2: a.m. and I don't want to commit
I don't want to get drunk It's 2: a.m.
I'm I got I got to be up in 6 hours like
quick someone give me a
moly I got to PP a moly a moly right now
I'm like
I I sit around for 30 minutes say hi to
some people I'm like all right guys I'm
going to bed like Okay and like this
story has just reminded me of about why
I stopped going clubbing this story
reminded me of why I don't ever go to
clubs I just man I I hate the whole this
whole like kind of um this kind of dance
that happens when you're trying to get
into a club and I'm sure if you've ever
tried to get into a club you know it
where everyone's like who who's on a
list who's uh who who's Who's down a
hierarchy you're just like am I am I can
I feel self-indulgent today can I feel
self-important am I part of the cool
kids you know why I don't miss dealing
with bouncers oh [__] hate bouncers
man they're such dicks and I just don't
care for it I like if they want to be
like if they want to be a [__] I'm like
all right well I'm just going to they're
just power tripping right yeah I'm like
these guys this is the like one moment
where they get to feel like like the
Orbiter of who is cool or not and I'm
like the dungeon master I'd rather just
go home and just watch League of Legends
I don't I don't F I don't care enough
about doing this dude this [__] this
so lame so yeah I did that and then the
next day it was like this razor DOL and
gabana party and uh what yeah it was
just in a club it was [__] and so we
we it sounds pretentious as F yeah
absolutely so we get into this club and
I'm on some list I don't know what list
I'm on you're always get some list I'm
always on a list for these streamer
things right cuz I hopefully some good
list well I you know what ends up
happening is that you i' I realized this
have to go in La a bunch after you reach
like a certain level of clout you can
just be like ask someone you're like hey
can I be on the list and they'll put you
on the list that just sounds like La in
general yeah but like I remember that
like I if I wanted to do this prior I'd
have to like if I wanted to hang out
with people I'd have to really like I
feel like a burden asking but now I was
like I was like okay I'll just can I
like do you want to come to this party I
was like I don't know can you just put
me down I just if I feel like it I'll
turn up yeah and so I was on a list or
whatever but then I ended up going in
with someone else who was on a on the
list this just I hate all this [__] I
hate this so much by the way capital T
the list and so we do this like John
Wick escort mission where we go up up
like up the club through the back doors
through like the the workers's entrance
the kitchen yeah through the genuinely
down in the elevator below the club
through the kitchen Good Fellas right
here three
elevators three elevators to get to this
club one down through the go and pass a
bunch of laundry workers go up again
through the kitchen go up one final club
we get in the special area of the club
which is just behind the DJ right and so
and I remember CU I was with uh we got
in it was like me lwig uh germa and RT
games and we were all there and we all
get in and and uh it's just it's so it's
so [__] we get to this club and you feel
like you're in a zoo because everyone
gets to see who's in the zone who's in
the VIP area behind the DJ right yeah
because and everyone's kind of like
elevated and you're just kind of on this
Podium behind the DJ and I hate this so
much cuz I'm like I don't want people
cuz people just this is people that
people do this and I think that like I
feel like your existence is so sad if
this is what you must do they stand at
like the entrance to the VIP and they're
just like looking at people waiting for
someone to like let them in right and I
guess at some point like the bouncer
like left so people were just walking in
and so there were like people who like
fans of the streamers started interact
it start to get really weird um and
there was not there was no drinks that
were aail aable to people in the VIP so
you to like you to like uh go to the bar
bring it back and it's just a whole SLO
I just couldn't be bothered that sound
like the worst VIP section I've ever
heard well yeah but it was sponsored so
I thought it would be like free drinks
for like the you know you want the
streamers to show up anyway so but
anyway uh I I have a drink and I'm
sitting there talking to talking to
germa and then at one point during this
one song this this is like we've been in
the club for 30 minutes by the way right
now and I I hate this already I don't
like this it's just too loud you can't
talk to anyone I don't I don't hate this
and um this [__] massive cannon goes
off like a a I don't know what it is
like a cold Cannon I don't know what
these things are at clubs they don't can
tell me do you know what these AR you go
to clubs this is this cannon that shoots
out smoke not smoke like cold air yeah
yeah I know what you're talking you know
the thing and it's so loud the one that
that that comes in like during the drop
like what the [__] hands up boom yeah
and it shoots cold air all over this
section and it is impeccably loud it is
like thunderous it is so impressively
loud that it literally like shocks me
and a few other people I'm with were
like what the [__] and like so loud that
you're like covering your ears cuz it's
just it's [__] yeah and so I'm like
I'm like I don't like this and and
they're all like yeah we hate this I'm
like should we just go this [__]
sucks and we're like yeah let's just go
so we just leave right away after 30
minutes um and and I feel like man I
spent 30 minutes getting in and I just
hated it and I was like I'm just going
to leave right away that just oh my God
that just sounds like that just sounds
like the Clapping experience it was
pretty [__] I just don't think I enjoy
clubs remotely suck man I just I think
there's never an occasion where I get
excited to go to one no no the the only
times clubs are good in my opinion is
when you don't plan for the nights is
when you get it can be like kind of a
fun little offbeat thing yeah yeah yeah
yeah I actually think the last time I
went clubbing was with you Conor Which
club would we go to huh which club did
we go to I can't it was like some Club
in you're never sober enough to remember
going no that's the point that's that's
well that's all the the club is fun yeah
that's that's it's it's it's one where
you like get a bit too Tipsy with your
mates and you're like I know this sounds
like a horrible idea because we're all
[__] drunk but clubbing clubbing
always starts with the pretense of
someone just saying [__] it the problem
is that the clubs get like way too busy
at a certain point and that's when I
even when I'm drunk I don't really enjoy
it kind of there's to like even if I
wanted to dance I can't really Dance I'm
shoulder to shoulder with
someone man I don't know if it's the
pandemic that did that to me I just
don't want to be in that situation ever
now flat out like I can be completely
drunk and I just don't want to be there
I'm like I just don't ever want to be in
the situation where I feel like I'm not
in control of my own space um and so
that was what all the clubs were like
because everyone in like twitch col was
trying to get into these damn clubs uh I
I just yeah didn't wasn't much of a fan
of it yeah do not regret not going to
twitchcon I thought that would be like
the kind of like Vibe and experience um
but that was like Saturday and Sunday I
mean the most fun nights when we just
got to hang out and just maybe maybe the
gambling that's the vibe that I like you
know I just like hanging out and
chilling and talking and it's going to
make me sound so old but just not being
in super loud places um I didn't dig it
I didn't not with it like for me every
time I've been clubbing it's always it's
always a sense of it's too loud to talk
to people but what I want to do is talk
to people yeah cuz uh unless I'm really
really [__] drunk I ain't going to
want to dance i' rather just hang out at
someone's house flat out like like just
House parties are goed House parties are
goed chill yeah I love it yeah not a fan
of not a fan of that so I don't think
I'll ever I think I just got to stop
admitting CU I kept trying to go to the
club being like maybe I'll maybe I'll
like it but I just don't I just don't
like it I hate it and the thing is it's
it's not even just normal Club it's a
club in [__] Vegas dude do you know
how much like a bottle costs it was like
it was like
$1,500 what insane insane numbers I
could be blackout drunk and I wouldn't
pay that you couldn't no way you could
get me to
P um insane amount insane amount for an
alcoholic beverage yeah um I because you
couldn't I think you could order
separate drinks you had to go to the bar
but if you wanted to bring the alcohol
to the table and have them like make
drinks for you it was like yeah that
much that's not including the tip either
oh no that's not that's not that's
expensive Jr so overall the whole
experience out of 10 TR con the com
itself
was there wasn't a lot to do it's kind
of hard to give it there's so many
aspects of it where I would write
differently like one issue I have with
the con itself as twitch conon is that
because they need so many sponsors for
it to be profitable it it's just like
one big ad and I feel like it's
literally just ads man discovers
capitalism but like you like I I like ax
I feel like they have like there's a lot
of really almost all of the the brands
feel in like like they belong at an
Anime Expo like I have a ton of crit we
all have tons of criticism oh so this
one just kind of felt like they're all
shoehorn in there's Chevron AT&T the
military it's just like a bunch of non
the military yeah my booth was opposite
the Navy Booth they were really chill
they were super shout out to the Navy
they gave us tools to to use on our
booth because otherwise we would have
had to pay to borrow them from the union
labor oh my god um and the the Navy was
super chill and they came up some of
them came up to me like hey I love your
stuff you want you want to like hang out
with us we got like a booth over there
so I I I almost signed
up I was like I'm British I can't
God no they were super chill they were
really nice actually uh they were a good
Bunch um I I think that they had some
space where they like had like they had
this whole giant area where it was just
PC setups where you could just play
games or stream I think it's a cool idea
but I think why they have so many
streamers why do you not have some space
that you can go to streamers and be like
hey is there some cool thing you want to
try and like a booth you want to make at
twitchcon that we could make that we can
advertise and use that as a poll like I
think it's missing so much like just
Creator involvement outside of meet and
greets because and shows they they have
some shows which are great and twitch
Rivals which which are great but it's
nothing the the viewers can get involved
with and I think that doing a meet and
greet is so they have so much room for
meet and greets and I think that a meet
and greet from a fan perspective is the
worst like the worst way that you can
spend your time to meet a Creator
because you line up for an hour maybe 30
minutes if you're lucky you meet your
creator uh and and if they're a big
Creator you probably will get 20 30
seconds to talk to them and I feel like
that's not a good experience like you
don't get a lot out of that as a viewer
and also the Creator cannot get to
meaningfully have a conversation with
you whereas I think if you do a booth
that's more interactive and the whole
thing is that you're going to be there
all day you're streaming you maybe
you're doing something cool you can have
more meaningful interactions with
viewers in a way that I think is way
more fulfilling and also way more way
better from the creative side um because
you're not just you're not just going
through this Mill of viewers just saying
Hi how are you how's twitchcon picture
hi have a nice day you know you're I
think there's a way better better way of
utilizing the space at twitchcon to kind
of allow creators to make creative
things I mean that's what I was trying
to do but the problem is that with from
a creative standpoint I don't have the
money that Chevron has to blow like
Doritos had like a double my space they
can just burn money because they're
Doritos I can't like I can't compete
with that like but it feels like twitch
should kind of be like hey we have the
space are there any creators that want
to use this to kind of do something cool
and I think that that's just such a
no-brainer from their perspective
because it's not like Anime Expo where
anime is the product in these anime
companies because they're coming up and
they're doing these things and it makes
a lot of sense but like streamers are
your product why are you not giving them
a space to show off why are you not
allowing them to kind of show off some
creativity and like have a presence
there where they can also then have
maybe uh you know the people from
Chevron will go and talk to them and be
like hey let's let's work together you
know we see your booth it's cool like it
feels like twitch con just is not
utilizing streamers at all like it feels
like they're not thinking about how they
can use some of the space cuz they had
plenty there's a ton of space being
wasted at that con the thing is I like I
don't even know what happens at
twitchcon I think if there was more
streamers who had booths who were
streaming or doing these cool events you
would you would see more stuff I mean
for for me my always my public
perception of twitch gone is just like
oh this is like party weekend for
streamers but they get to gather in one
building and yeah my idea for it was
this for stream yeah yeah yeah basically
basically just that right it's kind of
like yeah I mean basically yeah but I
mean VidCon vidcon's for like 8ye olds
yeah bcon also sucks I I think twitchcon
twitchcon has something and I I really
don't want them to keep doing what
they're doing because I feel like people
are just going to get bored cuz there's
no there's nothing to do at that con
there's not a lot to do like no
interactivity whatsoever there's like a
few things you can do the artist alley
is way too small you could you could
double the size of the artist alley cuz
I think that's the that's a highlight
for a lot of people seeing all these
cool things that like from Independent
Artists that they can purchase um and I
just think there wasn't like enough
interactivity for people to do things
they had a cool arcade section which was
nice but again that's like a small
little thing I think you have a product
that is streamers give them a space to
do something yeah um you know I think it
also kind of sucks from my perspective
where I'm trying to do something cool at
twitchcon and I have to pay an arm and a
leg uh and to be fair twitchcon did give
me a little bit of a discount but it's
like enough it's it's a you know and
they they did what they could but if
there was like some kind of framework
they could do where they could kind of
give out these spaces and have some kind
of pre-built thing that was you know I
think there's a lot there's something
that they could H they could do that
would really incentivize streamers to to
to get involved and also it would be way
easier for Brands to get involved with
those streamers there because that's a
win for everyone yeah I I I think I
think it's it's it's feels like a
no-brainer but I don't know why they're
not doing it I think there more
conventions in general need to do that
as well like not just twitchcon you know
like get get them more involved and get
people who are going to them more
involved so that there's actually a
reason to go other than oh I met my
favorite content creator for 30 seconds
yeah I just feel like cons really aren't
in general going in the right direction
for that kind of longevity yeah yeah I
mean it yeah there's a lot of cons I've
heard that are really fun to go to I
know that John always talks about
magfest and that kind of stuff being a
great fire oh dude the South Africa con
I winter was one of the best cons I've
been to just cuz there was so much cool
[__] to do there but like not a lot of
cons and in fact most cons 90% of cons
I've been to just don't have that yeah
you know yeah it just feels like such a
waste especially the only thing you have
as twitch is the streamer yeah give them
let them do something it's so it's just
frustrating from someone who wants to do
more creative things that I that's the
thing though like I feel not everybody
on Twitch has that mentality that you
have right like a lot of them just kind
of want to lay low and just like the
meet and greet is all they can do or all
they can hand yeah I think the meet and
greets are great but they had such a
massive area for it and I was like you
don't need this much space right uh well
it's just a statement right I think on
twitch's part they just like look at
what we [__] got you know yeah yeah
and I think there there was a lot of
meet and greets but again yeah I think
that like you can do which is why I
think we started doing more shows as
opposed to doing meet and greets because
in trash taste we felt that like a show
is a better experience for a viewer um
than a 30second meet and greet come to
our show come watch us live have this
enclosed experience with other
where it's great energy you get a show
like that's I think that's so much
better than doing a meet and greet CU a
lot of the time the meet and GRE like I
said you get 20 seconds to interact with
your streamer and that or your content
creator and that's it yeah unfortunately
a show takes a lot of efforts and energy
and planning and uh the end result is
always million times more wor the the
thing is is that it's easy to like I
think yeah there are L creators that
don't want to do that but there are just
as many creators that if you give them
the option they will go for it and
they'll try and be creative they'll try
and push it they'll try and do things
but without the option it's never going
to happen and right now the money just
it's far too expensive to do anything at
at something like a twitchcon yeah as
I've learned that I I I would it would
be very hard for for for me who is like
one of the biggest biggest streamers on
Twitch to justify doing anything so it's
like okay well this rules out like 99.9%
of streamers doing anything ever at
twitchcon like this is you know yeah
feels like a shame that's some
improvement this that they can like
hopefully hopefully hopefully hopefully
uh maybe I'll go to twitchcon next year
who knows I'm not top genin streamer
come on we need you I need the genin did
have a booth actually I know you could
have been there G I got invited to their
twitch Rivals I'm I'm going toilet but
yeah I was what I was actually invited
to go on the genin rivals number one
genin stream